[Music]
long ago there was a vast multiversal
war
countless unique timelines battled each
other for supremacy
but then the all-knowing timekeepers
emerged
bringing peace by reorganizing the
multiverse into a single timeline
now the timekeepers protect and preserve
the proper flow of time for everyone and
everything stepping off your path
created a nexus event
which left unchecked could branch off
into madness leading to another
multiversal
war welcome back everyone this is going
to be my new loki secret wars video
and for king the conqueror explaining
how they set him up in the marvel
universe during episode one his
connection to the timekeepers and the
time variants authority
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i'm doing videos for all the episodes
we're also doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and post all your theories about king
the conqueror in the comments
careful for spoilers from everything
that happened during loki episode 1 if
you have not seen the episode yet
but a lot of people saw that scene the
history of the tva as narrated by miss
minutes who's played by tara strong
she's the voice of miss minutes if she
sounded familiar but during that they
describe a big multiversal war which
essentially is
secret wars it also helps set up doctor
strange to multiverse of madness which
i'll explain
in a separate part of that big history
scene it's a big info dump there's so
many easter eggs just in that one
animated little short movie that they
played in the episode
but secret wars refers to a couple major
crossover avengers level events from the
comics
so there's the 1980s secret wars which a
lot of you may remember if you're old
enough
the story of that is very different from
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
the more modern secret wars
during the original 1980s one that was
the beyonder just testing earth's heroes
by bringing a bunch of them to a place
called battle world and just making them
fight each other battle royale style
that's also the event where spider-man
got his alien black costume it was
called the alien costume when he first
got it later they retconned that to be
the venom symbiote
that history video during episode 1
describes the more modern secret wars
multiverse war
event where you have all these alternate
versions of the characters from the
comics being funneled into a single
world after the collapse of the
multiverse
it remixes a lot of tropes from the
original 1980s secret wars event but the
scope is much bigger because you're
dealing with so many
alternate versions of the characters
from different eras in the comics
the difference in the loki series is
that sort of introducing time travel is
a much bigger factor
in this multiverse war but also this
multiverse war that they discuss
in this history video sounds a lot like
kang war in the comics which is
basically the new avengers team with a
different roster of new characters like
you have the falcon version of captain
america spider-man a couple other
different characters
versus kang teaming up with a bunch of
alternate versions of himself from
different points in his own timeline
and yes this middle time keeper the
second one here does look
very much like kang i mentioned this
during my loki episode 1 video i'll
follow up on this in a second too
because this is where we start to
connect things to kang the conqueror in
episode one
but a lot of you are confused about the
timeline here like why are they saying
secret wars in the mcu happened in the
past
the reason why miss minutes says that it
happened in the past is because the
timekeepers themselves didn't come into
existence until the end of time
the end of this current version of the
multiverse that we've been living in
during the marvel infinity saga movie
since phase one
a lot of you were asking if the eternals
characters were aware of the time
keepers if there's any connection
between the eternals movie and what they
were talking about during loki episode 1
the way they set the tba up during
episode 1 they basically erase people's
minds any time they come in to fix
things in the past and they didn't come
into existence till the
very end of the multiverse so it's
unlikely
that the eternals know about what's
going on with them because they were
created much closer to the beginning of
the multiverse so you have someone much
later in the timeline manipulating
things it'd be easier for them to erase
all knowledge of them
from beings that lived earlier in the
timeline the timekeepers themselves were
actually created by this being called he
who remains who was
literally meant to be the last person
left alive inside the multiverse
that means the galactus had died that
means the celestials had died
but he creates the time keepers and
empowers them to control the flow of
time and then the time keepers go on to
create the time variance authority and
this big citadel at the end of time and
start reorganizing the timeline which is
basically a reference to the sacred
timeline that they talk about in the
episode
so this really wondrous place that
throughout in the episode the timekeeper
citadel
wasn't created until after the secret
wars event happened in the future
so for them and everyone living here in
this little pocket dimension outside of
space time
secret wars happened a long time ago in
their past but for the other avengers
characters in present day after avengers
end game like
doctor strange spiderman thor this big
multiverse war
hasn't happened yet the connection to
doctor strange too multiverse of mattis
actually happens later in this little
explainer that she's giving when she
starts talking about nexus points
miss minutes says that if enough nexus
events happen and the tva doesn't fix
them
erase them with their time reset devices
it could create enough branching
timelines
alternate realities leading to a new
multiversal war
at a different point in the timeline
what did we see that other version of
loki do at the end of the episode who
possibly lady loki early theory about
who that is that they're chasing down
she steals their time reset device
preventing them from stopping a new
nexus event
so it sounds like she's going around
creating more nexus events and that
becomes one of the connections to doctor
strange to
multiverse of madness there'll be some
more connections to doctor strange 2
in loki episode 2 as well so i'll point
those out during my full
episode 2 video next week but miss
minutes very literally says
too many nexus points could lead to
madness in the multiverse
so it sounds like the way they're
setting things up in the mcu with marvel
phase 4
on the road to secret wars is that
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
is still meant to be a really big
bookend on this initial multiverse plot
like it'll get crazy with how big the
movie is
with the idea that doctor strange and
scarlet witch team up and they prevent
the multiverse from collapsing in this
other villain of doctor strange too
from completely taking over the main mcu
universe
but the movie itself serves as more of a
prequel like an appetizer to a
full-blown
secret wars event where you actually do
have a bunch of alternate versions of
the characters battling each other for
supremacy
battle royale across the multiverse
throwing in the fox x-men characters or
some of them hopefully they'll bring
hugh jackman wolverine back for that but
that's the path to doing the craziest
big crossover movie that you could ever
think of like you have a bunch of
alternate versions of iron man you have
the thor core with a bunch of alternate
versions of thor
any crazy version of any character that
you could possibly think of
the russos also were talking about doing
secret wars movies
ever since avengers infinity war came
out a couple years ago
they were just thinking about doing a
series of secret wars movies like you
couldn't just do it as one movie you'd
have to do it infinity war and end game
style where you break it into a couple
separate movies
but connecting this back to kang the
conqueror so during episode 1 there's a
bunch of easter eggs for him
specifically and they change some things
about the time keepers from the comics
to make the connections to king the
conqueror seem even more obvious
so during my episode one video i talked
about how this second time keeper in the
middle here that they keep focusing on
his face
he looks very similar to one of kang the
conker's faces
in addition to that during the animated
history of the tva video
you see what they look like in full
color their faces are blue
like kang's traditional face from the
comics but the middle timekeeper here
the one who looks the most like kang
also looks kind of like a depiction of
jonathan magers
as comic bookie kang the conqueror
jonathan magers is the actor who they
cast to play
kang in ant-man 3 quantum mania as the
main villain
we don't know exactly where he is in his
personal timeline during the events of
that movie
because some versions of kang later in
his timeline are more evil than others
and he didn't start out being evil but
this is some fan art of him as comic
book kang
does he not look similar to that second
time keeper
also some more evidence to back this up
during the episode loki makes fun of the
time keepers calling them space lizards
because in the comics they actually do
look reptilian two of the time keepers
here the first one and the third one
do look like they have reptilian
features but the second one in the
middle the one that looks kind of like
king the conker
looks more humanoid also in the comics
the timekeepers do make a contract with
a future version of kang
to rule over this vast section of the
timeline and keep order
that version eventually becomes a
mortise and rules over
all of time from a fortress that exists
in an alternate dimension
that looks a lot like the time keeper
citadel and in the comics kang the
conqueror is also the longtime love
interest of ravana renslayer played by
gugu um bottom raw in the episode
as judge renslayer she said that the
loki series is an origin story for her
character as well
and the way they frame most of her
scenes with her head transposed just in
front of this middle kang looking face
as the second timekeeper
just seems like they're foreshadowing
her connection to kang
or her eventual connection to him in the
future she was actually asked about this
specifically on kimmel recently about
her connection to kang on the series she
had a kind of awkward marvel sniper
answer like marvel will kill me if i
talk about this
the vibe you get from her character in
episode one is that she's kind of a
goody two-shoes kind of a teacher's pet
character who just does exactly what
she's told to do
well we're doing this we're
orchestrating the events per the
timekeepers wishes
because they wish it so loki sort of
points out the ridiculous nature of this
like how do you know with sacred how do
you know what the timekeepers want and
at least at this point in her story she
isn't questioning any of that the
sinister nature of any of this
so as mobius and loki go around hunting
down these alternate loki's learning
about more sinister things in the tva
sort of pointing out some of these
inconsistencies like mobius seems like
he also kind of understands that what
they're doing is a little bit sinister
like burn the place to the ground here
i'll show you to my desk so you can
start there
it sounds like ravana rensselaer's story
arc in the series is also discovering
some of these dark truths too like she
finds out that she's possibly been
misled this whole time as well
if you haven't read a lot of king the
conqueror stories as well he's also
deeply connected to the fantastic four
and obviously we're getting a new
fantastic four movie really soon he
started out in the comics as just a
normal human living about a thousand
years in the future he was born
nathaniel richards distant descendant of
mr fantastic
reed richards of the fantastic four he
became a scientist fascinated with
history and used time travel technology
that had been developed by dr doom in
the past
to travel to ancient egypt where he set
himself up as the pharaoh named
rama tut naming apocalypse the mutant as
his heir
later he comes back to fight the
avengers in present day with his
traditional kang identity and then
eventually he just pops up in the comics
at several points later in his own
timeline with different identities
like he becomes a scarlet centurion
version of kang then he becomes immortus
there are a bunch of alternate versions
of kang throughout his timeline
there's a teenage version of kang that
becomes iron lad in the young avengers
comics
so we'll see which version he's closest
to when we see him in ant-man 3.
my assumption right now is that we'll
see him both as the more human-looking
nathaniel richards and then they'll do a
version of his origin story or it'll
play out in flashbacks
somehow we'll see his origin story
becoming the full comic book kang
hopefully at the end of that movie just
setting him up as a larger avengers
villain he's just way too powerful and
way too big of a character
and way too connected to all these big
different comic book events for them to
kill him off one and done in a single
ant-man movie
also fun fact too talking about big
twists with the time variance authority
like everything seems kind of sinister
like somebody is being played here for a
fool
i know everyone's wondering if kang is
secretly manipulating all of this sacred
timeline business for his own personal
goals he does do that at a certain point
in the comics when he becomes immortus
but also there's a really cool setup
moment that i hope that they pay off
later this season
when loki is getting his sentence handed
down by judge renslayer
he says you bureaucrats won't dictate
how my story ends
most of the mcu characters so far have
referred to loki as the god of mischief
but mythologically loki is also known as
the god of stories
so we'll see if they're trying to set up
some similar type of agatha harkness
twist with the loki series like give me
akatha
all along but make it loki it was loki
all along
what greater trick could the god of
mischief pull than having another
alternate version of himself have a hand
in manipulating the tva
in the timeline himself tom hiddleston
was also hyping up loki episode 3
in episode four like this two episode
arc as some of the biggest
stuff that they do on the series like
he's most excited for people to see
episodes three and four
so it sounds like those will be episodes
where they reveal what's really going on
they kind of paced out the one division
series in a similar way where it was
like the last couple of episodes where
you start to find out what's really
going on with agatha harkness and
wanda's chaos magic
but if we see any more easter eggs for
king the conqueror or other versions of
loki that might be manipulating things
in the tva i'll point them out in my
future episode videos
my full episode 2 video will post
wednesday just like normal but i have a
couple other bonus videos planned before
that
and if you did spot any big kang the
conquer or secret wars easter eggs
during the episode that i didn't talk
about in the video
just write them below in the comments
everyone click here for my full loki
episode 1 video and click here for my
loki episode 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you